hello everybody and welcome back to the
channel I am racing to get this video
recorded before my roommates come home
and I also have to poop pretty badly so
I'm in quite a rush let's go ahead and
get started today we'll be covering
right skew and Phantoms
alrighty so I've got the iPad out so
let's go ahead and get into today's
lesson basically the subject of today is
Right skew which is another type of
database race condition so one database
race condition and this is kind of a
disclaimer that I didn't explicitly
cover in its own video is lost updates
uh the reason for that being that I
effectively covered lost updates in the
acid transactions introductory video
where you know one example is my friend
and I are both trying to modify a
counter and we both want to add one to
it but because I basically read the old
value and so did he one of our
increments gets lost and basically the
solution to that is just logging so
let's not worry about that we're going
to talk about right SKU so let's go
ahead and get into it basically here's
an example of red SKU so imagine that we
have basically an emergency room and
right now I have a table with the names
of the doctors and whether they're
active or inactive now one invariant of
this emergency room is that greater than
one doctor has to be active right we
need at least one doctor active at all
times so if a patient comes in with an
emergency see they can be tended to so
we've got Dr Oz and Dr toboggan
currently active but let's say that they
both want to take breaks Dr Oz you know
has to take a break to go grab some
tissues and lotion and toboggan just
went ahead and smoked some weed so now
they both want to set themselves to
inactive and they can basically just
both go ahead and do separate rights and
do that right inactive and then the same
thing goes for Dr toboggan we've changed
our status and now the invariant of the
database is broken and this is bad so
how can we actually go ahead and avoid
something like right skew from happening
well basically the solution is to use
locking but a little bit differently
than before so as you can see over here
on the left side of the screen we've got
three different locks and these are
going to be our row level locks all
databases have them you're able to
basically grab a lock on a row when you
want to be able to modify it but the
fundamental issue with right SKU is that
the two rows that are basically
affecting the invariant are not impacted
by each other's locks right if I want to
write to Dr toboggan I only have to grab
Dr toboggan's lock and I don't need to
grab Dr Oz's lock hence these two rights
can actually both go ahead and happen
and they can just grab their own lock
and there's never actually an issue with
the invariant however with right skew in
order to prevent it what we need to do
is actually go ahead and grab all the
locks of the relevant rows so in the
case of red SKU what we need to do is
grab locks
and we want to do it
where doctor is active
right so this way if any doctor wants to
go from active to inactive we have to
basically go ahead and grab all the
locks of the other active doctors this
way when Dr toboggan and Dr Oz tried to
go offline basically at the same time
they both try and grab the same locks
and only one of those rights is going to
be permitted to win the other is going
to fail so as you can see with right SKU
the solution is basically to grab more
locks of rows that you may not have
thought you needed but the truth is that
you do because even though these rows
aren't inherently related they both
impact the same database invariant so I
hope that makes sense let's move on to
another variation of right skill so this
one is actually going to be called
Phantoms so let's imagine that I'm in a
bakery right and it's me and Trump
because we're both fat and we love
cookies so as you can see here are two
existing rows in the database let's say
that Jordan went ahead and bought the
cookies right so that's an example of
the room and then you have my email
right there sexycodermanage gmail.com
similarly Trump went ahead and bought
the pie he's got carpets match drapes
yahoo.com but what if we were to both go
in there and try and get a cupcake
so we've got this row and I would go
ahead and write myself because I just
claim the cupcakes and then you know we
got our email blah blah and then
similarly Trump who's trying to get the
cupcakes at the same time also puts his
Row in the database
so a cupcake
Donald and then his email right
the issue now is that we've both claimed
cupcakes if there were locks on these
rows
it wouldn't even help us because the row
that we want to lock which is you know
this cupcake row right here it didn't
even exist yet we actually wrote a new
row to the database table so we couldn't
even lock it it literally was not
physically possible and that's kind of
the issue with Phantoms Phantoms occur
when two people
right
new rows
that conflict
and the issue with new rows is there are
no locks
to grab
if we can't both grab a lock it means
that you know our rights aren't actually
going to realize that they're
conflicting with one another they're
both going to go through and then we
have a broken database invariant so how
can we actually go ahead and fix a
phantom
this is by doing something known as
materializing conflicts so a
materializing conflicts basically means
is that for every row or basically for
every item in the bakery stock that we
could possibly have some sort of
conflict over we needed to pre-populate
that Row in the database so that we can
actually grab a lock for it we said the
bakery has cookies pie and a cupcake but
instead of just you know writing that
row into the database when someone
claims them we need to pre-populate all
of those rows in the database already so
that they can actually have a lock
object corresponding to them so in the
case of the actual cupcake you know we
have Jordan
we have Donald and we both want it to be
the case that we get our fields in the
name and email however what we're both
going to have to first do because
there's now a row that exists is grab
the lock for it so only one of us is
going to win let's say Jordan manages to
grab the lock first and then goes ahead
and writes his name here and then puts
his email over here it means that now
Donald cannot overwrite this you know we
just go ahead and say if there's already
a name in there that it can't be
overwritten and now Jordan wins and
actually gets the cupcake before before
we were able to materialize conflicts
there was no actual lock to prevent race
conditions happening and now the
invariance of our system were broken
okay guys well I hope that makes sense
uh as always hope the video is useful
and if you have any questions reach out
to me in the comments have a great day
and I will speak to you soon